more than 30,000 people are on the move
in the Philippines this morning as the
threat of a new volcanic eruption grows
II - all volcano erupted Sunday and is
now spewing ash up to nine miles into
the air a larger eruption could happen
at any moment
Raymie innocencio is that is in a gun Co
south of Manila this is the closest that
we can get to - all volcano there is a
police roadblock right behind me that
stopping people from trying to go back
home to get their belongings but tens of
thousands of people have been trying to
evacuate their towns covered in this
heavy grey ash and the government has
plans to evacuate hundreds of thousands
more that's because the volcano which
exploded Sunday with a 9-mile hike loom
of ash steam and rocks is now at alert
level four of five that means officials
think a hazardous eruption is imminent
for this popular tourism and farming
region it's already been spewing
Fountains of red-hot lava half a mile
high sparked its own spectacular
lightning storms turned tropical green
vistas gray and rocked the area with 50
earthquakes in just eight hours Tuesday
many families who live near the volcano
have fled to evacuation centers to wait
out the disaster
and health is a concern officials have
been advising people to wear masks to
protect themselves from this ash but
supplies are dwindling even in the
capital of Manila and some shop owners
are even taking advantage of this
situation by hiking their prices for CBS
this morning
rainy Inocencio agency Leo the
Philippines
you